Aquaman has netted a gigantic haul at
the box office with audiences and
critics enjoying the stunning deep-sea
adventure but how does the half human
half Atlantean superhero measure up
against DC's previous critical and
commercial sensation Wonder Woman
yippee-kay-yay be lovers I'm Jan and in
this video and comparing DC's two most
recent standalone origin movies /
Aquaman and Wonder Woman
keep watching to the end where I'll
reveal the same animated Easter egg that
was snuck into both movies and if you've
got any other upcoming movie should like
me to compare let me know in the
comments below this is one thing Aquaman
and Wonder Woman both succeed at its the
impressive scale of their world building
in Aquaman we get to visit all of the
Seven Kingdoms by the end of the movie
so there's plenty of amazing underwater
spectacle what's great about Aquaman is
that unlike some of DC's previous
cinematic releases it feels like
director James Wan has been given much
more free rein to indulge his
imagination without too much studio
meddling and the scale of the world
building makes me think of epic fantasy
flicks like Lord of the Rings which is
fitting because according to e w1
considers Aquaman a fantasy film not a
superhero movie so when we enter
Atlantis for the first time the visuals
are simply breathtaking going to give
props for that to the film's production
designer art department and VFX teams
there are plenty of arresting sites
throughout the movie and just when you
think it can't get any more insane it
does it's like a weird fever dream of a
film with so much to look at on screen
that at times you feel like you can't
quite take it all in while the movie
clearly lays out its own individual
world it's impossible not to make some
comparisons with other fantasy and
sci-fi worlds like Star Wars which one
cites as a major influence and
Atlantis's gateway bridge and border
control remind me of Asgard Bifrost
Bridge in the Thor movies and the light
colorful tone of Aquaman isn't miles
away from Thor Ragnarok the extensive
travels we go on in Aquaman mean we get
quite a mix of genres which I'll talk
about shortly and they also set up some
cool moments like the multiple wall
smashing action in Sicily and the
monstrous portrait like shot of Arthur
and Mara diving into the trench with a
littler and
then there's a crazy hidden Kingdom full
of dinosaurs at the center of the earth
which although inspired by comics in the
film feels almost like Aquaman as
briefly crossed over time and space and
landed in Jurassic Park when the woman's
world building is let's be honest a good
bit more restrained than Aquaman's
there's a lovely introduction to sir
mascara and the Amazons during the
scenes where we watch Diana grow up and
learn about the customs of her warrior
people though we do also get some
obvious green-screen moments such as
young Diana jumping off a wall and
Aquaman also suffers from some poor CGI
during flashbacks including the weird D
aging of Arthur's father and Willem
Dafoe's volcko in some ways it's a shame
the Wonder Woman movie doesn't spend
longer on the Paradise Island but the
story of course needs Diana to leave and
defeat Ares the God of War though the
movies design and art team certainly do
a marvelous job creating Diana's worlds
the locations we visit in Wonder Woman
are necessarily more grounded in reality
and their range isn't quite as rich as
in Aquaman where Wonder Woman did things
better is in exploring the mythology of
famous Kira and the Amazons rather than
Aquaman's somewhat brief flashback to
the formerly above Waterworld of
Atlantis Aquaman is a real whirlwind of
genres it's a bit like the filmmakers
decided to throw everything at the wall
and see what sticks there are moments
that lean heavily into horror which
isn't surprising given that the
co-creator of the sort and country
franchises is in the director's chair
there are action adventure sequences in
the vein of Indiana Jones The Mummy
movies and Romancing the stone with a
touch of The Fast and Furious franchise
thrown in remember that James Wan
directed the seventh film in that series
and the influence of Creature Features
also rears its ginormous head in fact
Wallace talked of Aquaman being a horror
monster movie on top of that as a ton of
Star Wars esque moments as well as
fantastical children's stories and
Arthurian legends thrown into the bland
some of these inspirations gel together
better than others personally I love the
horror heavy trench sequence when it
comes to Aquaman's tone though you could
certainly never accuse the movie of
taking itself too seriously which feels
about right given the characters history
director one isn't afraid to pile on the
cheese and an all-out efforts
the kind of humorous moments found in
old-school action flicks so as well as
bucketfuls of action and a lesson subtle
ecological message we also get a
boatload of jokes which depending on
what makes you laugh you'll either find
funny groan worthy or a mix of both come
aboard for me the humor in window woman
manages to find its target and lands
more often than not giving it an overall
better hit rate than Aquaman the
interaction between Diana who's never
seen a man before and Steve Trevor leads
to some truly funny moments as does
Diana's innocence when it comes to life
outside the mascara and how she just to
the new world like Aquaman Wonder Woman
also blends a variety of genres taking
us some swords and sandals territory
through screwball comedy to a war drama
with added elements of spy thriller and
finishing with the obligatory big
superhero battle compared to how well so
much of the rest of the movie works
thanks in no small part to compelling
performances from the lead and
supporting cast the finale feels more
generic even if it does give us some
memorable moments as for its villains
Wonder Woman isn't as wondrous as it
could be since its baddies are drawn
rather broadly so not especially
compelling Danny Houston's Ludendorff is
largely forgettable while Elena and I
are mix a bit more of an impression as
dr. Maru aka dr. Poisson given the
story's twists and turns David Thewlis
gets a few more shades to play with
though ultimately were still left with a
pretty typical CGI filled and battle in
Aquaman the villainy is really personal
from the get-go the main antagonist is
Arthur's half-brother orme
and the movie's secondary antagonist
David Kane aka Black Manta also has a
personal family based beef with Aquaman
Patrick Wilson's arm gets more screen
time than the individual villains in
Wonder Woman so in theory he gets the
opportunity to make more of an
impression but in reality like many of
the characters in Aquaman all has a heck
of a lot of not very scintillating
exposition to deliver in his dialogue
still opposite Jason mamoa is
hard-drinking tough but kill vipers
Aquaman the fact that Wilson plays armed
with all the gravitas and
self-importance for character straight
out of a Shakespeare drama seems
strangely fitting as for Black Manta we
only get so much of him and his
comic-book accurate costume this time
and he's basically there to be
introduced and built up as an important
future fo the Apfel man movie certainly
doesn't skimp on fights or battle scenes
showing us a vast range of
confrontations both below water and on
land including submarines taken over by
pirates gladiatorial style challenges
featuring a drum playing octopus
weaponized wine bottles storm-tossed
ships and deep sea dives as well as a
humongous sea monster voiced by Julie
Andrews and that's all before we even
get the final big underwater battle
during that climactic clash of the
undersea Titans we hear a character say
we are going to give them a fight that
they'll never forget which feels like a
lot of pressure to put on the movies
finale but there are definitely some
extremely eye-popping visuals in this
sequence there's after rising up out of
the ocean floor astride the Khorasan on
riding a masa saw that chomps up a
colossal crustacean and then there's an
army of laser shooting sharks plus a
huge array of other crazy creatures
basically Aquaman doesn't just embrace
excessive positively rebels in it it's
like the film is asking the question why
have less when you can have more more
more as much fun as this is it still
falls into the same trap of many other
such films by going on a touch too long
in the final stretch especially as the
scenes are almost entirely CGI and the
longer that's on-screen the more it
starts to look noticeable sadly Wonder
Woman is also guilty of that overly long
final CGI showdown with some ropey VFX
when Diana goes up against Ares however
there are some really cool fight scenes
in Wonder Woman that are especially
memorable for their dramatic settings
the Superman inspired alleyway fight
were Diana save Steve with her bracelets
is a delightful scene and there are some
beautiful balletic martial art style
moments in the battle between the German
soldiers and the Amazons even though
some of the effects may be flawed but
Diana striding out onto no-man's land is
the movie standout action scene nothing
in Aquaman is quite as visceral moving
and or inspiring as this moment and the
absolutely mind-blowing the amazing
thing about that scene is that it was
very nerve
from the movie as initially the studio
executives couldn't get their heads
around who diana was meant to be
fighting in the scene as it's not about
just one specific big bad now you know I
love my superhero movies but one thing
about though I'm not so keen on is their
romantic subplots because they often
feel shoehorned into the story and the
romantic interest frequently have less
than interesting roles but not a lot to
do other than be saved by and swoon over
the heroic lead while amber herds Mara
does get some cool moments in the
Aquaman movie holding back waves and
kicking some ass a big part of her role
is to relay information to Arthur and by
extension to us in the audience well
though mare is engaged to a Thurs
half-brother norm most of her scenes are
alongside Jason Momoa so it's
unfortunate that Momoa and herds
on-screen chemistry isn't exactly
sizzling it's not like the zero spark
between them it's more that their
eventual kiss doesn't really feel
learned but rather simply inevitable
because that's what happens in scripts
like this and that's why the way their
relationships depicted can't compare to
Diana and Steve and Wonder Woman
thanks to gal gadot and Chris Pines line
delivery and obvious chemistry patty
Jenkins direction and Allan Heinberg
script
Wonder Woman takes small quiet moments
like Diana and Steve's boat journey or
dancing together after saving a war-torn
village and turns them into humorous or
touching scenes that reveal a lot to us
about them as individuals and potential
partners so when Steve tells Diana he
loves her in the final act it's not a
throwaway moment that's inevitable
because that's what these movies do
instead the script has work to build
their characters to this point and
earned that moment much like her fellow
sea-based redhead Ariel in the Little
Mermaid Mara gets several literal
fish-out-of-water moments where she's
faced with a strange new world the
surface dwellers curiously Donna has her
own Ariel moment in Wonder Woman when
she drags Steve Trevor from the sea in a
scene that clearly pays homage to
Disney's animated feature okay now it's
your turn to decide whether you think
Aquaman or Wonder Woman is the better
movie I've added a poll where you can
vote just tap in the top right of this
video and after you've cast your vote
you'll be able to see the results let me
know what you think in the comments for
and if you enjoyed this why not hit the
bell and subscribe to get all my new
videos tapleft for another movie
comparison or tap write for another
video you're sure to like thanks for
watching and see you next time you be
gay with you lovers